Chuseok is celebrated on the 15th day of the 8th month according to the lunar calendar.
In 2016, Chuseok lands on September 15.
Typical foods made for Chuseok includes japchae, bulgogi,...
...jeon, the savory green pancakes, an assortment of banchan, and more.
These goodies are used for Charye, the ancestor worship ceremony.
Charye is set up at home on a wooden table in the morning.
Piles of fruits such as grapes, Asian pears, apples and tangerines...
...are commonly placed on this wooden table,...
...as well as dried jujubes and songpyeon.
Traditionally on Chuseok,...
...Korean families would also clean up the graves of their family members...
...and bow at the grave site.
They'd also wear hanbok and make their own songpyeon.
Songpyeon are rice cakes commonly made in the shape of half-moons...
...and are filled with sweet ingredients.